it's a waste of money dog I don't even
understand how that's even in the horror
genre dog
I'm just at least scared I ever been man
it's like like a romantic comedy
that's not lullaby dog yeah for reals
dog oh oh where'd you [ __ ] that
Ohana where were you punctured but yeah
I'm over that way boy
are you alway down there yeah well I'm
this way to it oh hi doc all right
no what was it I walk you to your car
like words bribe you back to your car
dick
a demon could possess any inanimate
object that's too general to be scary
how you gonna have a demon post it up in
a trash can it's unrealistic is what it
is like I ain't gonna be scared of no
trash can any what was that other thing
to have with the the the demon puddle oh
yeah yeah that was the most stupid pot
right there
a demon to pull you in the Hale if you
step in a puddle like we some [ __ ] I
mean how you gonna scare a couple of DOS
with a punch don't be stupid demon got
the hellhounds roaming around everywhere
bringing humans to the demon alive to be
Sapir you know it's like it's lazy story
yes yes is what it is it's a lot of
things but scary is not one of them
[Music]
yeah oh [ __ ] I'm sorry dog you tried to
wash that dumbass not scary movie yeah
you know that's how it go that's how
you